DANA PERINO AND THIS IS
"THE DAILY BRIEFING"."
JOE BIDEN NOW THE OFFICIAL
DEMOCRATIC WHITE HOUSE NOMINEE
ACCUSING THE PRESIDENT OF
FAILING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> OUR CURRENT PRESIDENT HAS
FAILED IN HIS MOST BASIC DUTY TO
THE NATION.
HE’S FAILED TO PROTECT US.
HE HAS FAILED TO PROTECT
AMERICA, AND MY FELLOW
AMERICANS, THAT IS UNFORGIVABLE.
AS PRESIDENT, I’LL MAKE YOU A
PROMISE.
HOW PROTECT AMERICA, I WILL
DEFEND US FROM EVERY ATTACK SEEN
AND UNSEEN ALWAYS WITHOUT
EXCEPTION EVERY TIME.
>> John: IN RESPONSE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP COMING OUT
SWINGING THIS AFTERNOON SAYING
DEMOCRATS HELD THE GLOOMIEST AND
ANGRIEST CONVENTION EVER.
>> THEY SPENT FOUR STRAIGHT DAYS
ATTACKING AMERICA AS RACIST AND
A HORRIBLE COUNTRY THAT MUST BE
REDEEMED.
IN JOE BIDEN GRIMLY DECLARED A
SEASON OF AMERICA DARKNESS AND
YET LOOK AT WHAT WE’VE
ACCOMPLISHED.
UNTIL THE PLAGUE CAME IN, LOOK
AT WHAT WE’VE ACCOMPLISHED AND
NOW WE ARE DOING IT AGAIN.
>> John: SHE IS COUNSELOR TO
THE PRESIDENT AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, GREAT TO SEE YOU
THIS AFTERNOON, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US.
I WANT TO GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REBUT THE
VICE PRESIDENT’S SPEECH LAST
NIGHT ON POLICY.
FIRST OF ALL, LET’S LISTEN TO
WHAT HE SAID ABOUT CORONAVIRUS.
>> WILL DEVELOP AND DEPLOY RAPID
TESTS WITH RESULTS AVAILABLE
IMMEDIATELY.
WE WILL MAKE THE MEDICAL
SUPPLIES AND PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT THAT OUR COUNTRY
NEEDS.
WE WILL MAKE SURE OUR SCHOOLS
HAVE THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
BE OPEN, SAFE, AND EFFECTIVE.
WE WILL PUT POLITICS ASIDE.
WE’LL HAVE A NATIONAL MANDATE TO
WEAR A MASK NOT AS A BURDEN BUT
AS A PATRIOTIC DUTY TO PROTECT
ONE ANOTHER.
>> John: THE VICE PRESIDENT
SAYING IN SHORT, HE WILL DO WITH
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD HAVE DONE
FROM THE BEGINNING.
YOUR RESPONSE?
>> IT’S A CONFOUNDING DISPLAY OF
IGNORANCE BECAUSE HE DOESN’T
KNOW WHAT WE’VE DONE ON COVID-19
COVID-19.
FIRSTLY, WHEN HE SAID IT’S YOUR
PATRIOTIC DUTY TO WEAR A MASK,
HE SOUNDS LIKE PRESIDENT TRUMP
WHO SAID IT’S YOUR PATRIOTIC
DUTY AND TWEETED OUT A PICTURE
OF HIM WEARING A MASK AND SAID
THAT IN THE SAME WEEK RECOGNIZE
PEOPLE CAN GO TO BARS, PLACES OF
WORSHIP, PLACES OF WORK IN
PLACES OF LEARNING SO STOP DOING
THESE BIG RALLIES AS WELL
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT BELIEVES
WHAT’S GOOD FOR THE IS GOOD FOR
ME.
VICE PRESIDENT ALSO SAID THINGS
YOU WOULD THINK SOMEBODY OTHER
THAN ONE WHO HAD BEEN IN
WASHINGTON 47 YEARS AND
VICE PRESIDENT FOR EIGHT WOULD
NEVER BE ABLE TO SAY WITH A
STRAIGHT FACE.
HE SAYING WE NEED TO DEVELOP PPE
IN THE UNITED STATES, GREAT IDEA
BUT THEY LEFT US A DEPLETED
NATIONAL STOCKPILE.
WE DIDN’T HAVE ENOUGH
VENTILATORS.
USING THE DOMESTIC PRODUCTION
ACT AND INCENTIVIZING PRIVATE
AMERICAN COMPANIES GOT ALL OF
THIS VENTILATOR CAPACITY SO THAT
EVERY STATE THAT REQUESTED
VENTILATORS GOT A VENTILATOR.
THE GOVERNOR IN NEW YORK SAID WE
NEED 42,000 VENTILATORS OR SOME
CRAZY NUMBER.
WE GAVE HIM 14% OF WHAT HE ASKED
FOR AND HE STARTED GIVING OTHERS
AWAY.
>> John: I THINK THE RECORD ON
THAT AS WELL ARTICULATED.
WHAT BIDEN IS SAYING IS THAT A
NATIONAL MASK MANDATE.
HE ALSO SAID HE WOULD NOT MUZZLE
HIS EXPERTS AND I THINK IT’S
FAIR TO POINT OUT THAT WE HAVE
NOT SEEN DR. BIRX, DR. REDFIELD,
DR. HAHN, OR DR. FAUCI IN PUBLIC
WE HAVE NOT SEEN THEM AT THE
CORONAVIRUS BRIEFINGS FOR SOME
WEEKS NOW.
>> IF YOU HAVEN’T SEEN DR. FAUCI
IN PUBLIC, YOU DON’T OWN A TV OR
COMPUTER.
HE IS A MEMBER OF THE TASK FORCE
WHO’S OUT THERE ALMOST DAILY
GIVING INTERVIEWS TO MANY
DIVERSE OUTLETS AND NONE OF US
HAVE EVER SAID PLEASE DON’T DO
THAT.
MY SEAT IN THE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE BRIEFING IS RIGHT
BEHIND DR. BIRX AND DR. FAUCI SO
WE SEE THEM.
>> John: WHAT ABOUT THAT
BRIEFING?
>> YOU MEAN THE PRESS HASN’T
BEEN ABLE TO ASK THEM RUDE
QUESTIONS LIKE THE ONE THAT WAS
ASKED OF DR. FAUCI ARE YOU HERE
ON YOUR OWN VOLITION?
IS HE PATTY HEARST?
WHAT IS THIS?
HOLD ON, THIS IS IMPORTANT.
JOE BIDEN SAYING THEY WON’T
MUZZLE THE EXPERTS WHEN OUR
EXPERTS ARE ON THE TASK FORCE
AND UNLIKE A LOT OF PEOPLE,
WORKING AROUND THE CLOCK HERE,
AND LESS TIME IT TAKES TO HAVE A
BABY, WE HAVE DEVELOPED SIX
DIFFERENT VACCINES AND AT LEAST
THREE OF THEM ARE IN THE FINAL
STAGES OF CLINICAL TRIALS
PEOPLE.
ALL OF THIS IS STILL A SIX MONTH
EFFORT THAT WE’VE BEEN DOING AND
THERAPEUTICS, VACCINE, SO A LOT
OF WHAT JOE BIDEN SAID WAS FALSE
AND IF YOU HAVE THE AUDACITY TO
SAY THE PRESIDENT DIDN’T PROTECT
AMERICANS AND YOU DON’T MENTION
THE VIOLENCE AND DEMOCRATIC
CONTROLLED CITIES, YOU’RE JUST
LYING TO THE PUBLIC.
>> John: LET ME MOVE ON TO
ANOTHER ISSUE, SOCIAL SECURITY
AND TAXES.
THIS IS WHAT THE VICE PRESIDENT
SAID LAST NIGHT.
>> FOR OUR SENIORS,
SOCIAL SECURITY IS A SACRED
OBLIGATION, A SACRED PROMISE
MADE THEY PAID FOR.
THE CURRENT PRESIDENT IS
THREATENING TO BREAK THAT
PROMISE.
HE IS PROPOSING TO ELIMINATE A
TAX THAT PAYS FOR ALMOST HALF
THE SOCIAL SECURITY WITHOUT ANY
WAY OF MAKING UP FOR THAT LOST
REVENUE.
RESULTING IN CUTS.
I WILL NOT LET THAT HAPPEN.
>> John: THE PRESIDENT HAS ON
AT LEAST A COUPLE OF OCCASIONS
THAT IF HE IS REELECTED, HE WILL
AND THE SOCIAL SECURITY PAYROLL
TAX, BUT IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THAT IS NOT THE PLAN, THAT
HE’S ONLY PLANNING TO CUT IT
UNTIL THE END OF THE YEAR AND
THEN FORGIVE THAT TAX.
WHAT IS IT AS FAR AS YOU KNOW?
>> THE LATTER IS MORE IN LINE OF
WHAT HE’S TRYING TO DO AND HE
ONLY DID THIS TWO SHORT WEEKS
AGO BECAUSE JOE BIDEN’S
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESS WON’T COME
TO WORK AND PASS ANOTHER PHASE
FOR SO THAT THE PRESIDENT WHEN
IT BE FORCED TO TAKE EXECUTIVE
ACTION ON HIS OWN.
HE ANNOUNCED AN EXTENSION OF THE
PAYROLL TAX THAT IS A TEMPORARY
THING BECAUSE HE WANTS TO MAKE
SURE WE KEEP THIS ECONOMY
HUMMING.
IN THE SAME ACTIONS, HE GAVE
$400 EXTRA OF UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS TO MANY AMERICANS AND
ALSO SAID HE WERE FREE FROM
EVICTIONS AND DON’T NEED TO PAY
YOUR STUDENT LOAN DEBT, BIG
MEASURES TO HELP AMERICANS.
THE SAME THING HE’S DONE AS
PRESIDENT WHICH IS HE WILL NOT
TOUCH SOCIAL SECURITY AND
MEDICARE.
THAT MADE A LOT OF RIGHT-WINGERS
VERY UPSET AND HE SAID I’M NOT
TOUCHING THEM, AND PRESERVING
THEM.
I WAS IN AN INTERVIEW EARLIER
TODAY WHERE HE WENT THROUGH THE
ENTIRE RECORD, MEDICARE PREMIUMS
ARE DOWN THE LOWEST IN SEVEN
YEARS.
HE HAS LOWERED THE COST OF
INSULIN TO $35 FOR SENIORS, HE
HAS DEVELOPED KIDNEY CARE
DELIVERY IN A VERY DIFFERENT WAY
WHICH HELPS A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
SUFFER FROM RENAL ISSUES AND
WHEN IT COMES TO SENIORS, THE
TELEMEDICINE AND TELEHEALTH
MEASURES THAT HAVE HAPPENED ON
THIS PRESIDENTS WATCH HAVE BEEN
NOTHING SHORT OF TRANSFORMATIVE.
WE HAVE 13,000 TELEHEALTH
MINUTES BY SENIORS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC BUT OVER 10 MILLION NOW
SO SENIORS CAN STILL ACCESS
TIMELY QUALITY CARE FROM THEIR
DOCTORS WITHOUT RISKING COVERT
EXPOSURE.
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON, HAPPY
TO PROVIDE IT TO YOU.
>> John: WE ARE LOOKING AHEAD
TO THE RNC NEXT WEEK, DAVID
PLOPPED SAID THE PRESIDENT HAS
GOT TO REACH OUT BEYOND HIS
FACE.
LET’S LISTEN TO WHAT HE SAID.
>> IS BASICALLY CONTINUING TO
DIG HIS OWN POLITICAL GRAVE, SO
THE QUESTION IS IS HE ABLE TO
CHANGE NEXT WEEK?
ARE THOSE VOTERS GOING TO HEAR
SOMETHING NEW, SOMETHING MORE
HELPFUL, SOMETHING MORE
DISCIPLINED WHO ARE WE GOING TO
HEAR ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN IN THE
ELECTION IS FRAUDULENT AND
BARACK OBAMA IS A CRIMINAL?
’S BASE WILL LOVE THAT AND WILL
CHEER AND THE REST OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
TUNE HIM OUT.
>> John: WHAT IS THE
PRESIDENT’S MESSAGE GOING TO BE
ABOUT?
WILL IT BE ABOUT THE FUTURE AND
WHAT HE WILL DO OR WILL IT BE
ABOUT JOE BIDEN AND THE
DEMOCRATS?
>> IT’S A COMBINATION OF THE
PROGRESS REPORT AND IT TOOK
JOE BIDEN LESS THAN 2 MINUTES
LAST NIGHT TO UNLEASH INTO
DONALD TRUMP.
AND I WAS SURPRISED BECAUSE ALL
WEEK LONG WE HEARD WE WANT TO
UNIFY A BROKEN COUNTRY, WANT TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT WE ARE FOR AND
NOT AGAINST BUT THEY DON’T KNOW
HOW TO BEAT HIM AND THEY
CERTAINLY DON’T KNOW HOW TO QUIT
HIM.
THE MOST POPULAR TWO WORDS WERE
NOT JOE BIDEN, THEY WERE
DONALD TRUMP.
IN THIS CASE, HE’S GOT SOMETHING
TO SAY ABOUT WHAT HE’S DONE HERE
IN THE 47 MONTHS, MUCH MORE THAN
JOE BIDEN HAS DONE IN 47 YEARS
BUT HAS A POINT WHICH IS WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF 1972 WHEN
INCUMBENT PRESIDENT NIXON HAD A
DECISIVE ADVANTAGE, FROM 1960 TO
2016, OUR ELECTORATE HAS ALWAYS
GONE FOR THE PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE THEY SAW AS MORE
FORWARD-LOOKING AND OPTIMISTIC.
THEY DID OTHER TIMES WHEN
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS,
PEOPLE WANT TO HEAR OPTIMISM.
THEY HEARD A LOT OF NEGATIVITY.
JILL BIDEN HAD THE MOST POSITIVE
AND UPBEAT SPEECH BUT SHE WAS
SINGULAR IN THAT REGARD.
THE PRESIDENT JUST TODAY SAID
JOE BIDEN’S SPEECH WAS WAY TOO
ANGRY AND GLOOMY AND HE BELIEVES
IN THE HOPE FULLNESS IN GREAT
NEST IN AMERICA AND YOU HEARD
THAT AT HIS JULY 4TH SPEECH AT
MOUNT RUSHMORE AND MANY TIMES,
SO HE WILL APPEAL.
THE OTHER THING IS NOT JUST THE
MESSAGE OF NEXT WEEK, IT’S THE
MESSENGERS.
WE ARE GOING TO SHOW THE REAL
PEOPLE IMPACT OF THE
TRUMP-PENN’S ADMINISTRATION BUT
FOR THEM BEING HERE AND THESE
POLICIES HAPPENING, THE SMALL
BUSINESSES WOULDN’T BE THRIVING
AND SURVIVING, INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE ADDICTED TO DRUGS AND ARE
LANGUISHING IN JAIL, THEY WOULD
NOT HAVE A FREER PATH FOR THEIR
FUTURE SO YOU WILL HEAR DIRECTLY
FROM THEM.
>> John: ONE QUICK QUESTION,
THE PRESIDENT A HANDY LAST NIGHT
SAID IT WAS HIS INTENTION TO
HAVE SHARES, LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
PROSECUTORS AT POLLING PLACES.
I ASSUME THESE WOULD BE PEOPLE
OFF DUTY BECAUSE THERE DOESN’T
APPEAR TO BE ANY PROVISION TO
HAVE ON-DUTY MEMBERS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT THERE AND WHAT
DO YOU SAY TO DEMOCRATIC CHARGES
THAT THAT WOULD BE VOTER
INTIMIDATION?
>> WHO ARE THEY INTIMIDATING AS
OPPOSED TO THE FOLKS WHO GIVE ME
THE SIDE I WHEN I TELL THEM
THEY’RE LOOKING AT THE WRONG
REGISTRATION RULES FOR MY NAME.
IT’S NOT VOTER INTIMIDATION.
THE DEMOCRATS AGREED WITH US
THAT ONE VOTE, ONE PERSON IS A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT IN YOUR
CIVIC DUTY.
DO THEY NOT WANT US TO SAFEGUARD
THESE ELECTIONS?
THEY CAN’T EVEN FIGURE IT OUT
AND THEY HAD THE POSTMASTER ON
THE ROPES TODAY AND INSTEAD HE
JUST SAID I HAVEN’T DISCUSSED
THIS WITH THE PRESIDENT AND
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN COMPLAINING FOR
DECADES ABOUT THE INEFFICIENCIES
OF THE POST OFFICE AND FINALLY
HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO IS WILLING
TO FUND THEM BUT ALSO REFORM
THEM.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING TODAY
AND THE POSTAL CONVERSATION WAS
A TWEET WHERE THEY SAID THEY
EXPECT BETWEEN SEPTEMBER AND
ELECTION DAY 2% OF ALL THE MAIL
WILL BE IN BALANCE.
THEY KNOW THEY CAN HANDLE THAT.
>> John: THAT IS A GOOD TEA
INTO HER NECK SECTION TALKING
WITH CONGRESSMAN DEBBIE DINGELL
ABOUT ALL THAT.